[Musik]
dritter september 2020
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
besucht die radarstation goldhaube am
kronsberg in oberösterreich
hier ist derzeit eine radarstation in
betrieb es wird aber bereits mit
insgesamt 21 millionen euro in eine neue
anlage samt infrastruktur investiert
nach einer einweisung durch den
kommandanten der luftraumüberwachung
zeigt sich verteidigungsminister in
tanna von den leistungen des
bundesheeres beeindruckt das ist
beeindruckend welche art und weise die
passive luftraumüberwachung der wirklich
im internationalen spitzenfeld auch an
der spitze ist die sicherheit im
österreichischen luftraum sicherstellt
um sogar darüber hinaus wie wir in einer
perfekten einweisung erfahren haben es
sind da wirkliche spezialisten und man
sieht auch das schritt für schritt
modernisiert wird die neue kuppel hat
ihren platz gefunden und das sage der
republik überwacht und schützt den
österreichischen luftraum die
radarstation dient der passive
überwachung des österreichischen
luftraums und das rund um die uhr
hier können flugobjekte in als auch
außerhalb österreichs in einem
erfassungsbereich von 470 kilometern in
alle richtungen detektiert waren die
aktive komponente wird derzeit von den
eurofightern soliden boden gestützten
systemen der fliegerabwehr truppe
übernommen